[Music]  wanna get rich playing video games all  right spot arrest it is wicked dangerous  [Music]  Showtime that's right all right let's  get you plugged in  Withey or is it wifey why don't we just  go in and we are online  cool  [Music]  super excited this one minor thing what  is the internet holy cow  look at all this stuff what's the prison  number six will amaze you ladies and  gentlemen the next item up they black  velvet painting of a sorrowful kitten  it's like it's looking into my soul yeah  that one's really gonna haunt me for a  while  [Music]  Thank You Lucy  good I don't understand why people like  this game raised in Boots shake it Peggy  Peggy the kitty for a little while  no the kitty gets the milk shake the  bunny okay  [Music]